i work with a lot of
enterprise customers and the biggest
question i get from them
is how does google do it how does google
build globally scalable services that
for the most part stay up things like
search youtube maps gmail
so today i thought what i would do is i
would actually take take you behind the
curtain and let's take a peek at what
that platform looks like from the eyes
of a service mesh
we've all heard things like istio and
anto service mesh but what do they mean
and how do i build globally scalable
services with that
my name is amir abbas i'm a solutions
architect out of san francisco
and i focus on distributed platforms
specifically with service mesh in mind
so this is kind of what we're going to
talk about we're going to really talk
about what does your application
actually need and
what kind of choices they have when it
comes to putting your application on a
platform
we're going to talk about multiple
kubernetes clusters and what does that
mean for distributed services
so most of us are kind of getting into
the world of containerization and
containerization and kubernetes are kind
of synonymous
so i'm going to take that one step
further and talk about multiple
kubernetes clusters
then we're going to take a step back and
really look at why service meshes exist
then we're going to look at the actual
service mesh implementation with istio
and anto service mesh and how they
actually perform and what they actually
do
and then we'll bring all of these
concepts together and build a platform
that can run globally scalable resilient
services
so let's get started let's start with an
application typically we think of
from a very infrastructure platforming
point of view right we think of what
does the platform need
i want to kind of flip that model and
let's talk about what do applications
need
and applications have a lot of choices
just in gcp we have these kind of three
main compute choices
on the far left hand side you've got
platform as a service with app engine
this is a very opinionated system that
you use
on the other hand of the spectrum you've
got compute engine this is
infrastructure as a service
doesn't give you any anything but it
gives you a lot of flexibility you have
to build the entire platform yourselves
now both of these are very extreme
on one side you're very opinionated
can't bring in any of the opinions that
you'd like
on the other side you're maybe too
unopinionated and you have to do all of
the work and all of the operations and
management yourself
but then along comes kubernetes and it
gives us a really nice kind of a middle
point
it gives us that automation and
abstraction away from infrastructure
and it gives you that gives us that
declarative way of deploying
applications
so great let's deploy our applications
on kubernetes but what we've learned is
that you typically don't deploy the
applications right on kubernetes
kubernetes is a great scheduler it's a
great container orchestration solution
but it doesn't give you
everything right you need to still build
a platform on top of kubernetes things
like observability
and security and software delivery that
all needs to happen
up top of kubernetes so all of those
opinions that you bring in kind of puts
you in the middle of this very
opinionated path
and somewhere in this kubernetes and
this is the arrow where that arrow sits
is kind of what we're going to talk
about today is where that is
let's talk about kubernetes so most of
us have at least started
to take the journey into kubernetes with
container orchestration and stuff
so why do we need multiple clusters well
since we're talking about building
globally scalable services by definition
we're talking about multiple locations
or multiple regions a kubernetes cluster
can only reside in a single region so if
you're in two or more regions you're
already in multiple cluster land
now within a region when i talk to
customers they talk about how do i make
my services resilient within a region
one way to do that is to have multiple
clusters within a region
two is better than one one goes down you
have something else
so we want to just kind of focus on
those two aspects multi-regionality
clusters in different regions and
regional resiliency multiple clusters in
a single region that gives you that
and this kind of spawns this idea of
something called a distributed service
the challenge with the kubernetes
service is that kubernetes services fate
is tethered to the fate of the cluster
that it runs on
now a service is a very important thing
that's your revenue generator that's
what makes you money
a cluster is just a piece of
infrastructure that just runs your
platform
it actually costs you money so tying
those two or tethering those two
together kind of doesn't make sense
distributed service at a very simplistic
definition is
how can i put the same service on
multiple kubernetes clusters that's what
a distributed service is it's a very
very simple concept
what it does it abstracts your services
life cycle from your cluster life cycle
if i'm running
on multiple clusters i can have clusters
going up and down
and my services can remain up visually
it would look something like this
so here i'm representing two regions on
the left hand side i have region one on
the right hand side i have region two
and then we have multiple clusters in
each region so on the left hand side we
have two
zonal clusters one in each zone a and
zone b and on the right hand side i have
two zonal clusters
and i have a single distributed service
running on all these four clusters
so not only do i have this service that
spans multiple regions
but it also spans multiple clusters
within a region so i'm getting
scalability and i'm getting resiliency
right i want to plant that idea because
it opens up a lot of
extra knobs when you think in terms of
distributed services
right things like i have to look at
service level objectives
at a service layer not at individual
workload running on each of these
clusters if i can provide my users with
the slo that i've promised them
it doesn't matter whether it's running
on four clusters or a single cluster
capacity planning becomes easier we've
heard terms like n plus one and n plus
two
if n is the number of clusters that i
need to run and satisfy the requirements
for capacity for a particular service
then n plus one and n plus two is can i
withstand a single
failure or a double failure so we
typically think of in terms of n plus
one and n plus two
can't do that with a single cluster
rollouts and rollbacks can be done at a
very granular level right so instead of
pushing out a new
version of your service to a single
cluster to every single cluster
i may want to just push out that new
version to a single cluster in one zone
and just have subset of my users use it
test it out and then kind of roll it out
to every single other cluster
internally at google we use terms like
draining and spilling and it sounds
exactly like
what it means if a cluster is having an
issue or if i want to upgrade a cluster
i can drain traffic away from that
workload running on that particular
cluster and
spill it to other clusters so i still
haven't taken my service down
but i've now freed up that cluster and i
can do whatever maintenance or
operations or upgrades that i want on
that cluster
so you can kind of see that when you
think in terms of distributed services a
lot of these kind of
resiliency and scalability knobs just
kind of open up to you
so i want to park that idea and let's
switch to why service meshes exist and
then we'll bring these two ideas
together
so for this i'm going to kind of go back
in time and
look at this monolithic application that
we've
heard so much about and what is a
monolithic application it's just a
collection of functions
but the first thing is a monolithic
application is not a bad thing it's
actually a very
deterministic it's a very good thing
when function a calls function b
it always works and it always works in a
very deterministic way
it's a function call i don't have to
worry about is the function b going to
respond or not
it is going to respond if it doesn't i
can just look at the logs and it's
usually the problem is in the code and i
can just go ahead and fix that
then someone smart comes along and says
we're going to containerize everything
and all that means is i'm going to take
those individual functions and i'm going
to run them as individual quantums of
compute
and that's what a container is just
functions running in
containers so the first thing we've done
is introduced this concept of a network
now this is
the crux of why service meshes exist
this is kind of the bane of the problem
is that we've taken a function call and
we've converted that into a network call
so the first thing we need is we need a
different way to connect these two
things together we need an interface
or an api for example most languages
come with their own apis or you can use
an
open source api library like grpc and
stick that on
and now you're good you've got your
client stubs you've got your server
stubs these things can talk to each
other
well that's great we've kind of solved
just the connectivity problem what about
security
we've heard these terms zero trust
network at a very simplistic term all
that means
is i'm not going to trust any form of a
network whether it's
an external internet or whether it's an
internal intranet
right so in traditional terms what we
typically do is we
really fortify the periphery of our
networks with very
solid big iron firewalls and we make
them very very
very very strong so it's very hard to
penetrate those walls but as soon
as you're in we just implicitly trust
everything on our intranet
as you get into the world of containers
and distributed systems
we've realized that even within the
network we need an extra layer of
security and this is the concept of zero
trust network whereas we're not going to
trust any network
each container and each service must be
able to identify itself
and this id becomes a very important
concept so that's the first thing we
need is now every service must have an
identification
must have somewhere to identify itself
to other services
now if i'm a developer and let's say i'm
just starting into the world of
containers i would
go and google you know python or go
security libraries and i would get these
libraries that kind of do this for me
and i would just implement those
libraries as part of my code and now
what i've gotten is
i've gotten things like authentication i
can authenticate myself to other
services
maybe even authorization am i allowed to
do certain actions to other services
and i can get things like encryption
because we don't trust the network we
don't want to have
open communication between these two
things now everything is encrypted it
doesn't have to have
happen over a vpn or over the same
network
the next thing we need is this idea that
networks are not
resilient right networks are very
unreliable when networks go down what
happens when container a calls container
b
and container b doesn't respond back
immediately what do you do
do you retry how often do you retry when
do you stop
you can build that logic inside of your
code
or you can get a network resilience
library again as a developer i would go
on google i would
google something i would get a library i
would slap that onto my container and
great now i've taken care of these kind
of network idiosyncrasies latency
fault tolerance things going down we'll
talk about circuit breaker shortly
since everything is now on a network and
networks are not fi
infinite resources we need to figure out
how to put network policies on things
how often can container a call container
b we don't want to bog down container b
if container a is just hammering this so
we need to be able to put some sort of
rate limits and quotas
on a per service level and maybe even
granularly on individual services
so now i need some sort of a network
policy and then last but not least
is observability which is probably the
biggest and the most important thing
when it comes to distributed systems is
what is happening
in my environment previously everything
was kind of hidden in the logs i could
just look at the logs in a monolith and
i could see oh this function has this
error
and this function is not working but now
i have is the problem in the network
is the problem in a request is a problem
in the api is the problem with security
so i need to measure a lot of things
things like metrics network metrics
things like distributed tracing most of
the time you're not just talking about
two containers you may be talking about
hundreds or thousands
of containers and a single request can
traverse very a lot of different
services and a lot of different
containers
and things like topology i just want to
see what my topology looks like which
services are actually talking to
other services now if you put a box
around all of these features that we
need
in the middle they all exist because you
have decided to take
a monolith and put that put those things
on a network these are not your business
logic these are not the things that make
you money
and these are very network functions
oriented thing right this is something
you absolutely need you cannot live
without these things you have to have
them somewhere what a service mesh
proposes is
why don't instead of putting all of this
logic into every single container and as
part of libraries
is there a way to separate your business
logic away from those network functions
and what that visually would look like
is i want to take this picture and i
want to convert that into this
i have my business logic now abstracted
away from all of my network functions my
identity my observability my policies my
authentication and authorization
since we live in the world of containers
we can toss both of those things in the
container
and in kubernetes we can put multiple
containers inside of a pod
now this is called a sidecar pattern
where you have kind of your primary
container that's your application
container that's running up
and then you have kind of a sidecar
container that's providing additional
functionality to that primary container
and that sidecar container suspiciously
looks like a network proxy because it's
providing a lot of network functions
envoy is a very popular proxy that's
used in distributed system that's used
for client-side load balancing because
now i'm going to slap this envoy proxy
to every single container there are a
lot of operational benefits to this too
i have a very clear kind of lines of
delineation between roles and
responsibility on who's doing what
above this blue line is my business
logic are my application developers
they can just now focus on developing
the application below this line are my
operators
they can focus on building the platform
putting policies on the platform and
forcing those policies
this is to me the kind of the true
definition of portability this container
now can run anywhere
as long as those functions is provided
by the platform and now i've relegated
these additional network functions onto
the platform layer
that are managed by experts that know
how to manage networks how to manage
security how to manage observability
so let's look at an implementation of
this how do we implement this thing
istio and anto service mesh are just two
of the implementation
istio is an open source implementation
of a office service mesh
anthos is a google managed service mesh
that uses the same apis uses the istio
apis
and i'm going to build the control plane
on the data plane at the same time and
i'm really just going to focus on the
functionality because i think that's the
important bits and the implementation
is not as exciting so on the data plane
we have a bunch of pods
with the envoy proxies running on each
pod and then we have this control point
and the first thing we need to know
is that istio and asm needs their own
service registry which is nothing more
than just a list of all the services
that are running
in the service mesh and all of the
endpoints on how i can get to it so
these are the ip addresses of each of
the pods
these could also be the ip addresses of
each of the vms
right so and it doesn't matter where
these pods are running it could be
running on a single cluster or multiple
clusters
with this get i get additional kind of
benefits of traffic management i can do
very granular things for example
if i'm deploying a new version of
service b or pod b which is pod b
prime and i only want to send a subset
of the traffic there now i can do things
like hey i just want to send 10
of the traffic to the new version and 90
of the traffic remains
my old version i can test out the new
version everything looks good and then i
can slowly ramp that new version
up observability where previously we
talked about logging was the only thing
in monolith that was important
but now we need network observability
network metrics distributed tracing
because these envoys are placed in a
very kind of a fortunate position
they wrap up all of these metrics and
they emit those in prometheus specs and
then you can send them to any collector
you'd like
so with istio and antho service mesh and
gcp automatically we ingest them into
cloud monitoring which is previously
known as stackdriver
but you can use any collector you'd like
security was another thing that we
wanted to talk about
right it's a zero trust network we don't
trust the intranet we want everything to
be encrypted
these envoys now are kind of the holders
of your identity and they hold a strong
identity they hold certificates a
certificate authority
with the shared common root can now
furnish the certificates to each of
these envoys
and on the basis of that they can now
authenticate to each other and they can
also do tls and encryption
between each other policy not only just
network policy we talked about network
policy right as
for example pod a wants to talk to pod c
and maybe
we've limited that to only 200 requests
per second
but authorization role based acts
authorization too which is
what can actually pod a do to pod c
right so it can do
a get and a post on these particular api
endpoints
that can also be done through istio and
through the onboard proxies
and last but not least is the platform
and the service resiliency
a circuit breaker is a common pattern
that's used in production
per service right so this is this idea
that if a service is having an issue
we want to be able to fail that service
as quickly as possible
and take countermeasures against it so
let's say we have a flow that goes from
pod a to b
to c to d and d is having problems
instead of that flow just continuing to
run and eventually just kind of cause
backwards cascading failures
we want d to quickly identify that i'm
having some issues
and the other services can then just
take counter measures and precautions on
top of that right so in this case let's
say
we put a rule that says if i see five
consecutive http errors
just consider me down go around me do
something else notify the user
tell them to wait or back off or any of
these logics that you can put in
and fault injection is something you can
do to test the resiliency of your
application
so how would my application work if i
injected a 10 error rate or if i
injected a 10 millisecond delay
this is also something one of my
customers used to actually test
something where they wanted to deploy it
into a different region that was about
50 millisecond away
and instead of spinning up an entire
infrastructure in that region they just
simply
injected a 50 millisecond delay and just
tested and observed what their services
are going to do
so these are kind of the six features
and functionality of the control plane
that are above and beyond what
kubernetes gives you service registry
works across multiple clusters
traffic management can can happen at a
very granular service per service level
observability gives you extra things
without having to instrument your thing
you get security and policy
above and beyond what kubernetes gives
you and then you get resiliency on when
kubernetes is having problems and
services are having problems
how can i automatically recover from
those particular services
so that's great so we have this
distributed services concept we have
this concept of a service mesh
let's build a platform together and
let's build that on gcp so the first
thing i'm going to say is that
a lot of these concepts can apply on
non-gcp environments too and we're only
going to build one environment so think
of this as this is my production
environment
and i'm about to onboard a service or a
product
in multiple regions and we're going to
just pick two regions because if you can
do this in two regions you can do this
in
20 plus regions so everything starts
with with a network and what we want to
do is we want to have a nice
flat network it makes communication
between pods and between pods and other
services
much much easier we want to kind of wrap
that around into a single
network in google we have a concept of a
shared vpc that can be shared to other
projects so we have this one project
project zero that's owned by your
networking team
and it gives them a centralized control
so instead of giving every single team
their own network
you have this one centralized network
they control the ingress and egress out
of that particular network and it makes
it much easier for services to
communicate with one another
inside of that we have projects now
project and google is just a collection
of resources
owned by a certain team or by a certain
function so in this case we're just
representing two projects we have a
platform admins project that's owned by
the platform admins team that's your
operator team
and then we have this product one
project right that's owned by a single
product team and imagine if you had
multiple products then you would have
project three project four and so on
when i think of projects i think of
three kind of levels of controls
billing is done at a project level so
anytime i want separation of billing so
by environment by team by function
it's a good way to put a project
boundary around it access management
is done at a project level so things
that are owned by let's say the platform
admins team should belong into the
platform admins project and things that
are owned by the product
team should belong to the product and
last but not least quota is done at a
project level
so where you don't want to share quotas
between different teams it's much easier
to just put a project boundary around it
we also put environments in separate
projects so here i'm showing a three
project setup for let's say the prod
environment you would have a very
similar setup for dev
and stage as well then inside of these
projects we put subnets subnets in gcp
and google are regional and we recommend
you use as
lowest number of subnets as possible so
here i'm representing two regions on the
left hand side we have region one on the
right hand side we have region two and
we have two subnets so that one and
subnet two you can have more subnets but
it's much easier to expand a single
subnet
and to have smaller subnets where you
didn't maybe size them right the first
first way ipam ip address management
becomes much easier you have to start
thinking about how many ips do i need
for nodes how many ips do i need for
pods which are the biggest kind of
resource
hogs for ips and for service ips we
always recommend using custom subnets so
not having
ip wastage by having these automated
subnets
inside of those subnets you have your
kubernetes clusters now these are your
your kubernetes clusters that are there
for applications as well as for
operations
so in this case we're showing six
cluster setup and they're
both identical there's three clusters in
region one three clusters in region two
if you want
other regions you can think about
horizontally scaling this out and
basically stamping this
exact environment in other regions as
well we have kind of these colorful
clusters the the orange red blue and
green
think of them as your application
clusters this is where your actual
services that are used by other services
are used by your customers are actually
going to sit
we'll call them apps clusters or
application clusters then you have these
two clusters at the bottom
the gray clusters think of them as your
operations clusters this is where your
shared services are going to sit this is
things like ci cd
tooling observability or in this case
the
asm or the istio control plane by
separating out your applications cluster
and your operations cluster we've kind
of separated out the life cycle of the
two we want to manage those
independently of one another
your applications probably will have a
much higher
scrutiny for slos and stuff and maybe
they're not being upgraded as often and
we want to maybe really kind of take
care of those
as opposed to your operations clusters
which can go down
for extended periods of time and it may
or should not affect too many things
so by separating those two clusters out
i have kind of granular control over how
i upgrade and how i maintain and operate
on these clusters
we start with a single asm control plane
per region
we can put a control plane in every
single cluster that's a perfectly viable
design and if you have small number of
clusters as a matter of fact that is
what's recommended
but then we've realized that as you grow
as you go beyond let's say
20 30 40 or 100 clusters then you would
have 100 control planes and it becomes
kind of an operational challenge and a
nightmare to kind of manage those
we also do a single control plane per
region
this way you're not dependent upon other
regions or regional connectivity or even
latency
within a region your latency is very
very small we put the control plane in
there in the ops cluster at the bottom
and now you can just continue to add
application clusters and they all
connect back to that single control
plane
and we've already talked about the
separation of life cycle management as
well as ownership where your application
clusters and your operation clusters are
owned by
could be owned by different teams so now
you have even though it's a logically a
global mesh
but you have these kind of regional
meshes that are
share that are kind of in a shared
control plane model so you have a single
control plane
sharing all of the clusters within that
region but both of these control planes
have
the full picture of the entire
infrastructure right of the of every
single cluster
then comes in namespaces namespaces is a
very important concept when it comes to
service meshes
in a globally scalable service mesh in a
single logical global
service mesh a namespace across multiple
clusters is
assumed to be the same thing so in this
particular case if i create a namespace
called product1 namespace
on four different clusters and i have
workloads running in these namespaces
from the istio service registry or the
anto service mesh service registry
perspective it's considered a single
distributed service
aha got that word back distributed
service we're starting to talk about
that
i'm getting regional redundancy because
i have multiple clusters within that
region i'm getting read
i'm getting global redundancy because
i'm running the same service now across
multiple clusters
i'm also utilizing my clusters better
because now i can create namespaces as
these landing zones for my services
i don't have to create separate clusters
for individual services
namespaces are the landing zones for in
this case product one
and that's what i'm renting out or i'm
giving out to that particular service if
i have product two product three product
n
those will all be name spaces that are
placed on these clusters
all part of the single global service
mesh and service meshes can talk to each
other
whether it's running in one cluster or
multiple clusters
and since all of these clusters are on a
flat network i never leave my vpc
everything is done on the same virtual
private cloud
so think of namespaces and landing zones
and think of multi-tenant clusters
always
multi-tenant clusters give you the best
resiliency so even in this example
i've got a product one service running
on four clusters technically again i can
lose three of these four clusters and
i've never lost my service
right so i can lose an entire region and
part of my other region and i have not
lost it
versus if i had individual clusters that
i'm not kind of amortizing between
different services
right now these product one services can
talk to other gcp resources that are
running
in project two in that particular
products
team so this is kind of a good way to
kind of think about how to manage
multiple clusters in multiple regions
how to overlay a service mesh on top
how to think about project hierarchy as
well as networking how to think about i
am and controls
uh this what we see is a good way to
kind of think about globally scalable
services and by the way this is how
google builds services internally
if you want to learn more and if you
want to build exactly what i showed you
you can go to the first link bitly
a dash workshop that will give you
actual terraform scripts on to build
exactly
what we showed as well as you can learn
about how to deploy applications how to
secure applications how to observe them
and so on
and if you want to learn more about
multicluster lifecycle management well
now i'm going into
six or seven or eight clusters how do i
upgrade those clusters and how do i
manage and operate multiple clusters
you can learn more on the blog series i
wrote it's a five part blog series
on the second link which is bitly gke
multi-cluster life cycle
that shows you how to upgrade one
cluster at a time in different
strategies of managing monitoring and
maintaining
your multiple cluster environment thank
you very much
you